what do you think about people that do
like actors that do their own stuff are
they [__] or what dude oh give the
drops to the stuff man they only have
money
[Laughter]
Tom Cruise bro it's cool come on give it
to us let us do it
[Music]
welcome back to another wonderful
episode of the careful boys today we
have with us Mr Sub and Choi
uh let me give you a quick introduction
to this dude we call him hustle boy Choi
he's a quest crew member he's also a
dude with like a thousand jobs when it
comes to a person that will work to make
his money and he wanted to work
before we and he's like like hey let me
work with let me work for you I know I'm
like shame he really lives up to his
reputation a man with a thousand jobs
yeah he grew up in Hawaii
um he lived in Sacramento as well moved
to LA this dude for a time he he even
worked on dietrich's channel when I was
working on it oh yeah he uh so in
addition to be a dancer he's also a bud
tender at a dispensary he also is a
stunt performer now he's also a barber
to the stars in The Stunt World he cuts
everybody's hair wow are you good at
cutting hair dude he's amazing yeah
while on a motorcycle yeah and he does
motorcycle stunts too yeah what that's a
challenge we could do that so he's like
idle adjuster oh this goes on its own
how did you join Quest how did you get a
request [__]
sir
I saw them in Hawaii one time yeah and
then I was like
oh dude I'm gonna join their crew one
day so I freaking just you know like
secretly like what do you call it when
you don't pay
so you know the 50th state fair that
they have in Hawaii Quest Crew performed
there in 2009 this fool snuck into the
show that where it snuck it snuck into
the show dude and I told him I was
getting beer and I landed in La one day
and I was like yo I need to figure out
how to work for D-Trix and I saw his
place was like all dirty and [__] and I
was like
I'm gonna clean this trash real quick
and just see what happens I cleaned up
his trash if you don't have to do that
and I was like it's okay
but I got you I got you and then you
know it's slowly uh snowballed into me
working for him and then boom boom one
day he asked me to do a job with him
because he he couldn't do it or
something in New York yeah yeah like a
dancing job wait so did you just follow
the crew all the way from Hawaii like
I'm going back to L.A no the creepy
snuck into the airport I moved to
Sacramento okay he's from Sacramento
yeah yeah and now I moved to Sacramento
from Hawaii from Hawaii and I went to a
school and I hated it because it was
just a bunch of you know I was just like
damn which is why people everywhere
compared to Hawaii and I was even the
Asians were white and I was like dang so
I was like you know what I'm gonna just
do a dance class and as soon as I was
doing dance because I looked to my ride
it was a picture of Dietrich
in the dance club in Wood Creek High
School oh wow yeah and slowly snowballed
into fighting his crew in sack moving to
LA
hey
you played the long game no that was a
stalker I was just like it's a goal
oh okay I like that yeah are you a
stalker I'm just go oriented he provided
values he's dedicated is it is it really
stalking though if you're just satellite
stalking
satellites well satellites like the mood
no no like I mean
why are you stalking me man every night
I [__] see you
he's not bothering dietrichs yeah but
he's within his sphere of influence yeah
yeah oh sad oh I see yeah satellite
stops like a hack it's a hack what if
someone came to uh Lionheart Jiu Jitsu
to get closer to me I bet that's
happened I bet that's how or what if
they're trying to get close to Colleen
I'm never there but then but they're
like Nick can I work for you so I could
so I could one day join Colleen's film
company and then I'll be like that's a
mess over there can you clean that up or
something and then that'll start okay
it really did happen like that because
there's like three Hawaiian dudes like
him and then brownie who you know and
then Mark Mark villover and they're all
from Hawaii and these dudes we would
hang out with them and we're like yo
they're just mad cool and they're all
really good so then eventually we just
picked them up and it's so funny this
dude like having him around just makes a
big difference like anywhere you go all
right wait were you already dancing back
then were you into like yeah were you
were you guys a b-boy crew like you and
Brownie and everybody you knew each
other there or was this no I knew
brownie in L.A which was weird oh like I
would see him in Hawaii all the time but
I was like nah
bro you and the other crew I don't care
about you he comes to L.A I'm like yo
and I seen you all the time you're dope
okay bro we're
let's be best friends and I you know
we're brothers
[Laughter]
okay Hometown people you're like [__]
that guy and then you're like oh my God
you're in New York I'm in New York too
let's hang
here we are yeah he's very he has a lot
of like very Hawaiian traits and very
Sacramento trades and La trades really
what are Sacramento traits he's like
sheisty you know he's like shady
[Laughter]
what is a Sacramento trade
it's like I like Sacramento I like
ripping on set because I know we have
people inside that watch and then every
time I rip on Zach they're in the
comments like hey that's messed up we're
not shy I love playing with them no but
he's like one of those down ass homies
that you know like is gonna fight like
the first guy to fight always like if
that's what it's called is that the
Hawaiian trait if she's going down he's
the first guy to fight for sure yeah
Hawaii
no you're scared you're gonna lose but
you still have to say yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah because your homies are all around
oh you know what it is very Hawaii
because one day this food was hella
drunk outside of uh we went to like some
Ryan higa's party oh God when he when he
like came out with that milk and then we
were uh this fool got super drunk and we
were outside I'm trying to brawl some
Ryan Higa fans no but like it was after
at the end we were in downtown outside
in this car drove by and they like you
know people just yell [__] and then this
fool started yelling back all crazy and
then the car like slowed down and then
as soon as that happened his other two
Hawaii friends were like all right guys
we got a [__] fight now and then they
all just like I don't remember it's like
the unspoken thing yeah
and they were like without any
hesitation and these dudes never the
other two dudes do not fight but then
they were like oh well I mean we gotta
have Steven's back yeah I was like damn
that's pretty cool Hawaii and you ended
up not even fighting District
he's like I don't remember that he was
throwing up so much that I started doing
flips over
I saw that video
he's like he's like a a man's man he's
like a guy's guy kind of dude you know
what I mean is there a a quest
initiation like like when do you do you
guys have like a council I think we're
ready to bring another one in yeah we
just go to Korean barbecue that's
literally all we do really yeah
like we do we I mean it's not is it a
boat not really are you the leader that
tells everybody I mean it is it is a
vote but there's never been like a split
vote usually it's one of those obvious
things where like if anyone's bringing
it up it's probably very obvious that
everyone agrees at what point do you go
yeah you know what it's been a long time
they've been around it's I think it's
time for them to Quest it up let's
purple it up bro I think once you're
just naturally homies it's it's already
unspoken it's like dude it just feels
right anyway you know what I mean
because we were hanging out so much and
this dude's been there for so many
things and helped out with so much stuff
like dietrich's Channel everything yeah
and he's just a he's a great dude so how
do we get in the quest
oh hey you know another thing another
thing that you might know uh subin from
and you guys might know him from this
too
he was in a viral video uh that uh it
went pretty big on Tick Tock how many
views did this thing get
I don't know it's all over bro
so
I'm just talking over it yeah
driver
s
why are you saving lives bro do you cut
his hair on the motorcycle too
holy [__] dude you're a gangster okay I
can't move you need a haircut you need a
ball fade I could work for you
no I got off work early so I was like
damn so much time let me just say this
guy real quick bro what the [__] yeah
dude that [__] semi trucks he went
into traffic to save this dude's stalled
car cover time there's not too much cars
no I would never do that
I found a version where there's a guy
talking I thought that was funny but
this isn't the original
oh he couldn't move
no but like he's stuck in the seat no
he's knocked on the freeway
he's stuck in this he's stuck in the
center console sat on some maple syrup
man
she's still stuck in the seat
look like check the camera's rolling
it's good it's rolling bro this is crazy
yo tell us about that [__] bro what was
why couldn't he just he was scared to
get out of his car
supposed to
what about himself you know I'm saying
there's cars passing by him there's so
many cars swerving around him yeah yeah
he's actually dangerous bro yeah bro I
remember one time we were driving back
like late at night from Long Beach right
and then we're on the carpool lane and
then we see this figure there's this guy
so the car stopped and he's by the back
of his trunk going like this and we're
like oh [__] you're the one driving fool
oh that one yeah oh God tell me more no
that one was crazy because Bart was
sleepy too so he was like oh [__] so
then he saw him out of nowhere and then
he uh swerved right and then we uh we we
all we heard like in the back was
boom and then we look back and then
there was this truck that rear ended it
and I'm like I
I didn't get smashed in the middle
I was in Long Beach on the 110. yeah it
was it was it was uh yeah 405 I think
like on the way from Long Beach to yeah
it was dark and then it was just like
we're just driving and then all of a
sudden you know when you like see
something at night yeah it pops up in
front of me it was a guy like this
behind his car and I was like oh [__] I
go like this as soon as I go like this
right behind me boom and I'm like
pretty sure he's alive I'm pretty sure
yeah
I really bet what do you think
I'm pretty sure she even save them no
you guys ever checked on them no we were
too far away
we're too far we can't go back and I'm
not from Hawaii oh that's true yeah yeah
and that was during a time when it'd be
illegal to check on him yeah there was
no GPS back then so like when you get
off the freeway you don't know how to
get back on yeah that was a long time
ago yeah how many uh how many views
total did that oh yeah we're [__] old
bro uh
Mill
but then it started going on everyone
else's different channels so they
reposted it yeah I sold it to viral hog
so what happened at the end when you
helped them out did you guys just leave
that area just left the car there yeah I
told him like all right you got it he
said all right got it and I was like
okay
well the cart wait the car got started
running no no no he just stopped there
in the off the and then so wait you just
got him out of the car which is more
dangerous pretty much and then if you're
just standing outside now yeah and then
people are like look at this hero he got
him out of the car well I just got I
just made sure he was out of the freeway
yeah oh what did you do did he hop on
the back of your bike and then he held
your hips and then you just went blah
blah and then you would you pulled up to
the side what'd you bring it on your
bike no no I wouldn't I didn't have a
back seat like that oh okay well I told
him to call entrance and I don't have
any I was like all right good luck buddy
I already got you out of here that's
great dude
I've never pulled over for anybody ever
flat tire any of that stuff wow I don't
I don't that's definitely an LA move you
did that a second time didn't you for
like some girl that was like fighting
with some dude oh yeah oh you know what
I did on Garfield there you go um there
was an old man
it's because I saw it like in slow
motion where I can like actually make a
move but I'm like in on Garfield heading
uh towards Valley you know that one uh
restaurant that they always burn down to
claim bankruptcy that's what they're
known for damn it's a seafood restaurant
there's this old man who's standing
there this [__] truck backs up with
the uh the tailgate lifting sticking out
oh and the old man is just like hands
behind his back [__] like looking
around and then that thing [__] hits
him in the head he drops on the floor it
just starts blood gushing everywhere so
I pulled over and then why was he just
standing there he owed and then you know
like Asians always have extra napkins so
I have a stack of McDonald's napkins
that I put on his head and then I found
out he had family and I told him to hold
it like this
let's see
little by little but then old Asian men
are curious so he's just probably
outside like [__] staring around like
he's behind the back for me
but that was because I saw it and I had
time to versus like boom what the [__]
and then it's hard to go all the way but
if someone like let's say a motorist was
flagging you down you would never if
someone flagged me down I would I would
probably oh really but just like I'd be
suspicious nope but those flat tire ones
not really I'm like man everybody got
flat tires yeah you would you would stop
only if it's like in the middle of
nowhere not in L.A if it's in Hawaii
yeah 100 and they're micronesian no a
thousand percent
yeah I think it's a move if people have
resources and they should be able to
save themselves I'm not gonna stop but
if they don't have resources then I
would help them yeah because in the like
let's say we're in the middle of the
desert then it's probably like some [__]
with like no reception or it might be
like book a Eli move where they're like
hell and then you pull over they're like
all right give me all your cars and
monies yeah you know but then we're not
in post-apocalyptic times so I think it
should be fine yeah yeah true
would you do that you don't seem like
you would do that look at his ears it
depends on the situation Nick would
leave the car with guns drawn it's the
old grandma and he's like I'm watching
you [__]
and then she's like my car's out of gas
he goes should have [__] paid for a
full tank dude I think he got me spot on
I think that's what I would if I had a
gun I think that's
what oh wow yeah that's I would I'd be
that but why didn't you fill up yeah
what are you a [__] idiot yeah that's
what I would say you don't need a gun
though you practically are a gun your
ears are a gun yeah yeah those are guns
right here dude
[Laughter]
that's crazy but yeah Superman also does
stunts and uh and he works with uh a ton
of different stunt guys been on some
movies and and TV stuff you may have
seen what what made you get into stunts
you just like to fall
he's a wild boy no just my my friend was
like
I was breaking and I was like yo there's
no money in this
so this what is this dance that I was
like come on join question but by the
time I joined rescue They're all playing
games and they're all doing businesses
I'm like y'all wanted to dance he joined
after like the end of their career so
you didn't do the ABDC stuff no I wanted
to uh I was cleaning watching ABDC
you go on Quest two let's go
why don't you just fall on your back for
money and I was like what is that he's
like stunts and I was like
that is sick I'll totally follow my back
without even Landing a move I try to
follow my back for money I said let's
just do that yeah that he said that man
stunts is way easier it's like breaking
but you don't have to land your moves
yeah that's actually hard but it takes a
lot of skill though to fall right yeah
that's what I thought at first but when
I got into it I was like holy crap this
is different level of
training you gotta hit your mark timing
can't hit the actors oh yeah it's
actually harder didn't you just get
really messed up recently from a job
like you got hurt right like your leg
Yeah Yeah well no just my head I just oh
just your head okay yeah I was supposed
to do like a 180 to my shoulder yeah on
the fifth one they said go harder
I landed on my head oh
it's all good though because you woke up
like oh he's gonna play dead let's play
dead you don't have to land your move
and you're you can't go ow nope you
can't go owie no how often do you train
like stunts throughout the week because
I'm sure oh I've been doing it every day
so far just trying to treat y'all like
crash pads and soft stuff to like yeah
dude yeah yeah yeah yeah damn what do
you think about that recent stunt that
uh Tom Cruise was doing where he um
motorcycle yeah he did it like six times
six times yeah and then each time he's
like no I think I could let go like
later let go later and then he was like
[__] pretty much base jumping and
then pulling the shoot that's insane
what do you think about what do you
think about people that do like actors
that do their own stuff are they [__]
or what dude oh give the drops to the
stuff man they only have money
he doesn't even give them props like yo
why are you taking my job Tom Cruise bro
come on give it to us let us do it
you think Tom Cruise just trying to save
money you think that's what it is I
think he likes it yeah
I think he was trying to save money yeah
but Tom Cruise yeah Jackie Chan sitting
there with a calculator like oh no
that's so expensive I'll do it then you
paid these guys dimes anyway I'm with
Chinese dude I was like hell no you want
to do more uh driving stunts because I
know you were taking like courses for
drifting and all that stuff whatever
yeah no it don't matter it's whatever I
can get my hands on everything we're
Troy man what's the scariest stunt
you've ever done have you come close to
like actual like death or
no last year was like the only real job
I really had what does that mean there's
a lot of fun
not really anything
this is what I had to do is
and there's a Porsche the camera guy and
the camera that was the scariest job I
had to go 15 miles per hour without
hitting the camera
oh she said you're going a little too
slow
look at stuff I'm trying man hey you
gotta go a little five miles per hour
I'm like yo what what I'll just kind of
pace the car perfectly yeah but their 25
is different from the car I'm in 25 and
they're like yo you're going a little
too fast I'm like oh oh what's going on
don't hit the camera yeah
don't hit the camera hey can you look to
the side and act a little bit whoa that
was scary just a little bit yeah cause
you hit the camera and it's like this
guy's never getting hired that was the
scariest yeah and we're in public Street
too so like hey watch out for the people
I'm like
kind of panicking a lot of pressure can
people watch out for me that was the
scariest why did they just put it on a
flatbed and then you could pretend to
drive hey I'm not the corner
I want to get paid dude
I would have told him why yeah this is
more dangerous well we don't need to pay
you anymore like why did I bring that
uh damn it now they can just use an
actor